deve continuare a breve ci obbliga
nazionale il gretto sisto bravo sei
mento navigli fondamentale per stata
chiesta
assolutamente si dovesse giudicare
secondo il mio vedere potrebbe averli
non voglia di avervi di mezzi messi a
metà del xii secolo non innamorarsi arti
giravamo dal montante destro
mi sembra un pò stanco anche detto che
la sinistra
nella francese
per primo io sono felice così le devono
ancora dice poi subito anche con il
mancino giusti ci proverà a chiudere per
un po la guardia altro destro dirlo è la
testa
donato supino
spero
balle
non vuole cedere la decisione fascia
sinistra
ancora non è la sinistra
questo
non si è visto
vogliamo diventare
c'è la vittoria
ma lì un po fossi io vorrei partire la
guida alla mia amica sconfitta e questi
casi in pochi sono ancora fasce questo
combattimento poteva farmi arrivare tra
nella vita mondiale tra i primi 10 5
e mondiale dal titolo europeo è qui in
questo ultimo round provato a superarmi
erano sul tetto d'europa fino alla
decima ripresa quando diritto appunto da
nove minuti dal sogno è una forte
disidratazione ha fatto le mie fuori
quello che è successo a disidratazione
impedito che potessi portare a fine temi
che a queste system in aree incolte
scusate ma sono un convenzionale di
solito sono più abituata con 4
questo per me vuol dire che vuol dire
andare oltre
io sono etero ma penso questo uomo mai
13 giugno dell'anno scorso
il mio pensiero ho visto tutte le
mattine tutte le sere quando mi alleno
ecco vorrei fare un passo indietro
perché vorrei intricate cosa c'è dietro
lo sport è così perché era uno sport
individuale come appunto è la boxe c'è
tanto sacrificio tanta passione 0 di
contanti
molti fanno finta di conoscerlo ma
realmente pensa che sarà riposa
conoscere quello che c'è dietro il diano
veramente la vetrina di tre ore e mezzo
tutti i giorni compresi alzavano infatti
dopo di questo intervento
prima ad allenarmi e poi sono fusi che a
siena dove tra l'altro dovevo combattere
questa sera a un piccolo infortunio
permetterà di portare a termine
neanche questo è con te e niente detto
questo io mi alleno dalle tre ore e ore
e mezzo al giorno e due volte a
settimana mi devo spostare il rapinatore
vedete un po tahrir hanno un unico
anziano e il mio allenatore e due volte
settimana ha risposto allena e una volta
settimana a firenze
tutto questo sembrerebbe una cosa
diciamo sì un po di sacrificio ma una
cosa tra domande se non che ho trovato
lavoro sono riesco a portare anche
queste due vite parallele un impiegato
non è semplice molto sacrificio e per me
questo potrebbe andare anche oltre le
aspettative che teoricamente tutti i
professionisti come il mio caso
abbandonano quella che mandano più che
il lavoro vero e proprio che si danno
alle forti totalità e velocità di
guardare alle volte anche perché un
progetto che che devo per forza per
toccare con mano
io devo riuscire a lasciare in qualcosa
di importante anche chi frequenta la mia
palestra
noi abbiamo box tra marchi di arezzo
fanno abbastanza famosa in città
ho iniziato ci spiega io data 99 che
sono in palestra prima allenato ancora
piccola non era ne stia cercando
decisivi ancora situazione abbiamo molte
comunità ci portano questi ragazzi siamo
pari con i disagiati che cosa così
arrivati dove ci sono persone
normalissime come noi abbiamo qualche
caso umano come lo chiamo io
vai a livello e l'amicizia tutte le
pressioni che non combatteranno mai che
non hanno interesse a combattere si
allenano provano a fare qualcosa ma
quello che mi dà orgoglio quello che
riesce a mandare avanti perché sono
tanti sacrifici che è stato sono andata
a convivere per riuscire a vedere nella
compagnia talmente riuscito neanche a
stare insieme e quello che in quello che
mi piace il mio progetto è riuscito a
lasciare qualcosa queste ragazze ha
portato in famiglia porta nella nostra
famiglia loro che purtroppo io non è la
famiglia a loro non ce l'hanno
la maggior parte di perché questo a me
qualche problema viene in palestra e si
sente a casa
io non contento sono contento di essere
riuscito a diventare il tempo di molti
di questi lidi questi ragazzi si
ripetono con alcun interesse anzi il più
delle volte offerto economicamente
qualcuno una caletta premature rimasta
guantoni quindi delle volte sono io che
io io il presidente che mettiamo la mano
al 2 serve però questo non è
assolutamente un problema è vedere di
uscire un progetto di milano un anno un
anno e mezzo di uscire
diciamo realizzati e tornano magari con
un bambino sposati ecco per me quello è
il risultato è il risultato della boxe
chiesto chiaramente fare qualcosa dietro
detto questo all'interno assolutamente
abbandonare il mio credo di legno sport
né cosa principale contro la qui a fine
anno di poter essere altra volta
l'avversario del campione se attualmente
secondo in europa e stiamo cercando
insomma di rifarci strada
ora vorrei parlarvi di quella che per me
forse il momento peggiore la merita non
vado sulla livello sportivo perché quel
combattimento ha segnato anche un
problema fisico e sono stato rimodellato
diversi giorni perché si pensava che non
potessi neanche io combattere il colle
ha subito avuto una forte disidratazione
e
non riuscivo neanche a parlare in
all'inizio della decima ripresa non
riuscivo a far male che riuscivo neanche
a camminare trovano le decisioni non
mollava passati altri 5 minuti da quando
ho sentito il quesito che poi per primo
all'ultimo sintomo perché non è che ti
avverte arrivano in vista di
ritrattazione e non riuscivo neanche a
camminare
però pensavo solamente una sembra banale
come ricorda ma io pensavo solamente a
tutto quello che non è riuscita a creare
io sono diventato un fonico ora per
questi ragazzini di 15 16 anni che
vengono in palestra per ripensare molte
cadute che magari chi chi chi chi si è
lasciato che ricorse altro che ha
problemi coi figli vengono in palestra
si scaldano riescono con due parole una
battuta riusciamo delle famiglie
ecco io non potevo far vedere che alla
prima difficoltà avremmo andato anch'io
altrimenti cosa cosa che cosa fatta cosa
dico ai ragazzi come luciano l'angolo
cosa cosa io avuto a parte lei quindi la
cosa non torna e quindi io pensavo lo
pensavo alla mia famiglia
e pensavo che le uve rami pensavo che
tranne che il sogno correvano suoi poi è
rimasto quattro minuti perché dopo
cinque minuti purtroppo languida
interrotto ma meno ma l'inter ormai ha
mai ceduto non sono andato giù non sarei
mai andato giù
meno male interrotto due interventi è
qualcosa che poteva compromettere ecco
io ho dato un incontro sono ripartito da
quell'incontro voglio ripartire sono già
ripartiti ho già fatto altri
combattimenti con due vittorie per ko
nonostante ciò mi sembra rotto le mani
altri due volte quindi finire davanti
tra un'operazione combattimento
operazione compatto
per l'appunto siamo fattuale altra volta
e spero spero ovviamente di riuscire a
portare solo il titolo è una cosa
personale ma di riuscire a portare
questi che sono i miei ragazzi mi chiamo
così in un mondo anzitutto di un mondo
di ormai un corpo
vorrei dare un futuro a loro vorrei
riuscire attraverso i miei vittoria
attraverso la mia affermazione in campo
europeo e mondiale
riuscirà a dare un qualcosa anche a loro
diciamo questo è il mio progetto il
progetto diventato più progetto divino
perché tanto che arrivati che la boxe è
uno sport che ho deciso di fare la boxe
decide di rifare la boxe e quindi di
lasciare qualcosa non posso farmi
scappare questa occasione anche è
diventato la mia strada
io vorrei vorrei concludere con la
speranza che la vostra idea magari da
un'idea comune dinanzi a un po cambiato
di quella che il pugile alcuni
personalmente una persona un uomo che
sapeva con tanto sacrificio e porta è un
sogno nel cuore